We are at the Harlem Buyer Fair which is
a an industry event that we produce
under the Harlem Local Vendor Program, a
partnership actually between Harlem
Park-to-Park, Columbia University, Hot
Bread Kitchen, and Harlem Community
Development Corporation and West Harlem
Development Corp as our funders and the
program is really designed to help local
entrepreneurs, product entrepreneurs,
scale their businesses so that they can
pursue supplier partnerships with local
stores, corporate stores, and corporations
for distribution. So today's event is
actually the culmination of 11 month
program that these vendors have been
participating in and they have been
learning how to develop their business
working on their packaging their product
their pricing learning operations
manufacturing to get to the point where
today they actually get to pitch their
products to buyers we have buyers here
from Whole Foods Market, Fairway, Fresh
Direct, corporations like TD Bank that
are all looking to bring in products
into their companies for distribution
and so it's very exciting because we
already have some success stories here
today of vendors whose products are
being picked up for distribution